I think we have senator Ted Cruz
standing by senator you there senator
Cruz are you with us thank you for
joining us
so we I'm gonna ask you the question
that I asked de rooy you're watching
these pictures you followed this for the
past three days what do you make of this
where do you think it's going well
listen it's horrific and it starts with
a horrific act of police brutality
you know anytime you have a police
officer involved shooting that the media
often goes into a frenzy and there is an
immediate demonization and attack of the
police officers and I think that's wrong
I think it's premature that being said
in this instance we have a video of the
incident and we can see with with mr.
Floyd the officer with his knee on his
neck for eight minutes mr. Floyd has his
handcuffs he's clearly incapacitated
he's begging for his life and and what
we saw was wrong there's no legitimate
law enforcement purpose for what we saw
right there I'm sorry senator let me
just let me just operate there and just
ask question I and I agree with you I
found the video very upsetting and there
I mean there's a lot of abuse of power
by a lot of different people in charge
including the police sometimes do you
believe since let's just deal with facts
here do you believe that the man in
custody died of suffocation
because the police officer was sitting
on I don't know we'll have to see what
the medical evidence shows but what
wasn't I do wait all that isn't that
isn't that the question I mean either
the cop killed him or he didn't I mean
no the question is was that abuse of
authority and police brutality and it
was definitely an abuse of authority but
the guy's been charged with murder so
isn't the question whether it killed him
or not well there are two separate
questions number one the Department of
Justice opened a civil rights
investigation that was the right thing
to do I applauded the the Department of
Justice for doing that number two the
prosecutor chose today to bring homicide
charges now to prove that they will have
to prove that the evidence supports it I
don't know what the medical examiner is
going to determine on that
so whether or not it was homicide will
depend on the evidence but it was
clearly police brutality and it was not
conduct we expect of any officer an
officer is entitled to totally I totally
agree with that I think it was awful
I've seen that kind of a covered cops
I've seen that kind of thing before and
I hate it
however the country is convulsing on the
basis of the idea that a cop killed this
man who was restrained he was in
handcuffs and I just like I think it's a
meaningful question it's not something
we could have lied over him like oh it
doesn't matter of course it matters why
wouldn't it matter
Tucker saying that the criminal justice
system will operate and it will depend
upon what the evidence is and whether
the case be proven to the jerk is not a
lighting over it it's saying no no it's
not and I agree with you 100% there and
and one of the reasons sadly that we are
seeing the this violence in this rioting
is that you have a lot of demagogues
that want to use this incident of clear
abuse by one police officer and they
want to use it to paint every police
officer as corrupt and racist and and
most police officers heroically risk
their lives to protect the communities
they're in often minority communities
and and and for everyone that is
stirring up racial division and engaging
in violence and looting that is
completely unacceptable violence and
criminal conduct is unacceptable whether
it is committed by a mob in rage or
whether it's committed by a police
officer who's breaking the law the law
should have bribery and you need
everyone so why is that so difficult for
so many Republicans in Washington to say
I saw the tape I was horrified by it the
guys should be punished for doing this
and you're not allowed to burn our
cities down and yet I've heard basically
silence from the party that I've kind of
routinely voted for for all these years
rethinking that now but why doesn't
anybody stand up for the rest of us
civilization like you're not allowed to
burn cars how's that you're saying it I
have you yeah I can't speak for others
but it's an obvious reaction enforce the
law protect people's lives protect
people's rights and in a point out you
know there is some irony that that in
Minneapolis the local officials the
state officials the Attorney General the
governor both senators they're all
Democrats and you get a lot of people
who are playing
this for partisan advantage and yet you
know one of the unfortunate things about
a lot of elected Democrats and we're
seeing this during the corona virus
pandemic is that they're willing to be
authoritarians they're willing to be
States they're willing to send people to
arrest dads for playing softball with
little girls or women paddleboarding and
it's if you believe in Liberty then you
want to see police officers keeping
people safe and not abusing people's
rights or liquor couldn't agree more I
couldn't agree more and we've seen this
is not I mean we've seen a lot for puce
actually recently let me ask you just a
question and I don't know if it's
answerable but you know you've watched
this country closely for a long time
what do you think this is going look I
think we've always had demagogues and
and we've seen you know you and I are
both old enough to remember Rodney King
and his plea can't we just get along I I
would like to think that we can instead
appeal to our battles better angels I
think there are an awful lot of people
whether black or white or Hispanic that
want to come together as one America
particularly at a time when we are in
have both the public health crisis and a
massive economic crisis dividing us and
turning people against each other is not
good or beneficial as much as the media
loves to do it I I think that's what she
just said is absolutely right and how
nice would it be if we had leaders who
could bring us together I mean that
would that would just be the greatest
thing of all
um Thank You senator good to talk to you
tonight